In an age of revisionist fairy tales like
Frozen, Maleficent and Into The Woods, Disney
stay relatively old-school in the live-action
remake of their classic 1950s animation, Cinderella.
Downton Abbey star Lily James brings a genuine
sweetness and lightness to the role of the
good-hearted Ella whose stepfamily turns her
into a skivvy, nicknaming her Cinderella.
Richard Madden, who's best known as Robb Stark
in Game Of Thrones, gives a charming performance
as the Prince.
And James and Madden make a perfect on-screen
pair.
As Cinders’ stepmother, Lady Tremaine, Cate
Blanchett shows, yet again, what an exceptional
actress she is.
You won’t be able to tear your eyes away
from her whenever she’s on screen, whether
she’s doling out chores and making catty
comments to Cinders, scheming her way up the
social ladder, rolling her eyes at her talentless
offspring, or draping herself over furniture
and in doorways.
Think Bette Davis meets Joan Crawford. In
short, Blanchett is sensational.
Holliday Grainger from The Borgias and Sophie
McShera from Downton Abbey also do a great
job as Cinderella’s spiteful and selfish
stepsisters.
And the always brilliant Helena Bonham Carter
swoops in as Cinders’ Fairy Godmother and
almost steals the show, despite having just
one scene.
In fact, she’s so fantastic that she leaves
you wishing she had more screen-time.
Still, we do hear her voice throughout as
she narrates various parts of the film, and,
in a nice touch over the end credits, she
sings Bibbidi Bobbidi Boo from Disney’s
animated Cinderella!
Speaking of music, there’s a lovely score
by Patrick Doyle, who’s worked many times
before with Cinderella’s director Kenneth
Branagh and whose music you’ll have heard
on other films such as Pixar’s Brave.
Except for the folk song Lavender’s Blue,
there aren’t any songs in the film and,
to be honest, I did miss that, especially
given the classic songs we know from Disney’s
animated features and the superb live-action
feature Enchanted.
If you’re wondering what the movie’s transformation
scenes are like, let me tell you that they
are just spectacular – a dazzling, dreamy
delight.
There are two transformations you’ll be
expecting, the ones before and after Cinders
goes to the Ball, AND there’s a little extra
surprise to look forward to.
That’s all I’m going to say about that,
as I don’t want to spoil it for you!
Oh, and just as you’d expect, the scenes
where Cinders arrives at the palace and dances
with the Prince are brimming with old-school
style.
Costume designer Sandy Powell has done an
incredible job, creating the most staggeringly
stunning costumes.
Essentially, she’s a shoo-in for the Oscars
& BAFTAs next year.
From the gorgeous 1940s-inspired gowns Cate
Blanchett wears, to Cinders’ servant girl
costumes and her beautiful ball gown, to Helena
Bonham Carter’s fairy godmother get-up,
to the stepsisters’ deliberately gaudy matching
garb, the costume work is faultless.
And I just loved the wonderfully garish ball
gowns worn by the tasteless stepsisters – they
looked like they’d eaten several tons of
Quality Streets chocolates and then dressed
themselves in the wrappers!
As for the worlds of Cinderella and the Prince,
they’re beautifully detailed and rich, thanks
to production designer Dante Ferretti.
And cinematographer Haris Zambarloukos, whose
work you’ll have seen in Thor and Mamma
Mia!, gives the film a magical sheen.
British director Kenneth Branagh’s take
on the Cinderella story is an unashamedly
sweet slice of cinema which focuses on the
three c’s: courage, kindness and oodles
of colour.
Given the hyper-cynical era we live in, it’s
kind of a bold move for Branagh to shine a
nostalgic light on a character of such unalloyed
goodness as Cinderella.
As for the look of the film, there are lots
of lavish-looking crane shots that sweep up
and over parts of the palace as well as the
landscape.
They do look great but start to feel a touch
overused as the film progresses.
Oh, and if you’ve watched many Branagh films
before, you’ll know that he loves a good
circle shot, where he swirls around his actors,
and Cinderella is no exception as you’ll
see when Cinders and the Prince first meet.
And it really does give their meet-cute a
kind of appropriately dizzying quality.
Screenwriter Chris Weitz mainly sticks to
the traditional tale we all know, making some
nice nods to the original animation throughout.
He does throw in a few noteworthy changes,
too, including an early meet-cute between
Cinderella and the Prince, which makes it
feel as though the pair are on a more equal
footing, despite the difference in their status.
Weitz also adds some nuance to Cate Blanchett’s
wicked stepmother, and he answers our potential
questions about why Cinders doesn’t just
run away from her horrible stepfamily and
why they don’t recognise her at the Ball.
While I’m not a huge fan of the movie’s
opening scenes, which take us through Cinderella’s
childhood and last a little too long, they
do fit with the dreamy, fantastical, magical
feel of the whole film.
So, to sum up: Cinderella is an incredibly
colourful and charming confection that brings
to life Disney’s classic animation by tipping
its beautifully tailored hat to nostalgia.
Cinderella gets 4 out of 5 Flicks.
What did you think of Cinderella?
What’s your favourite Disney movie?
And how excited are you to see that Disney’s
also making a live-action movie of Beauty
& The Beast?
Let me know in the comments below!
If you like this video, hit the thumbs-up
button & subscribe for my weekly movie reviews
and interviews!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!